Okay.
So as you,
you may have noticed the course has been proceeding,
uh,
somewhat historically,
first with pre primate animals,
the whole evolution of sex from things that swam in the ocean.
Uh,
and then we discuss the primate a mating system as,
as you've seen as in the same census on the board.
And so the first,
the,
the pre primate is,
uh,
a few millions of years,
I'm sorry,
tens of millions of years.
Primates,
uh,
maybe 10 million years or so.
And then last time we started discussing the transition from ape to human and,
uh,
evolutionarily modern human state to something like 150,000 years ago.
So we're moving,
we're coming up to time and today we're gonna discuss fully anatomically modern
humans.
They have the same brain capacity that we do,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
The earliest groups that we have any kind of decent demographic data on our
hunter gatherers,
which would include caveman and,
and people that are a hunter gatherers per do not live in caves.
And,
uh,
last time we asked why there were so few chimps in so many humans.
And today we're going to ask very similar questions about,
we're going to start with,
we're going to cover a lot more.
We're going to ask very similar questions about hunter gatherers.
Uh,
there were not,
there never was a great density of hunter gatherers.
They're certainly not now.
And the question is why.
Um,
if you look where hunter gatherers live now,
they eat each small group and again,
the small group is the same size we've been talking about something like 40 are
spread out over very large area and they use that area to hunt in and to collect
fruits and nuts and whatever they can get,
uh,
from the trees.
And so it looks like a very simple question.
Why is the density of hunter gatherers so low?
Why are there so few of them?
I,
and for a long time,
the answer was they didn't have much food,
that they needed all this space to get enough food to survive.
And if they overpopulated that space,
they,
they couldn't survive.
And in sort of modern a Hubris,
we looked back and thought the hunter gatherers and very inefficient form of
food gathering.
Not Modern and,
uh,
we're,
we're so much better than them now.
And,
uh,
the data is quite clear on,
on some part of those assumptions.
Uh,
hunter gatherers,
uh,
at the time when all human beings,
we're in the stage of hunter gatherers,
uh,
before farming starts about 10,000 years ago.
Um,
there's,
uh,
what is the number here?
Uh,
there may have been like 2 million people on the whole earth.
Remember I said Hunter Hunter gatherers spread out of Africa,
spread amazingly over the whole of earth.
And maybe the total population of humans at that time was something like 2
million people.
Now we have over 6 billion people.
That's an increase of 3000 times in the human population.
So clearly there were fewer hunter gatherers then than now.
And this is a very,
you'll see this in lots of discussions of,
of this field,
but it's a very elementary kind of consideration.
It talks about the long scale of human demography,
of human population growth.
And we came out of being,
uh,
other species of primate of hominids and are we gradually grew up to some sort
of a limit.
There's the idea that the various in a productive systems that we use,
uh,
like hunter gathering,
limit is some sort of a carrying capacity limit.
And so the idea is that the human population increased until it reached the
limit.
And then for a very long period of time,
it can't get beyond that limit.
And then 10,000 years ago,
maybe it's 12,000,
uh,
farming is invented and all of a sudden the whole system changes.
There's many more people.
And we jump up and then again,
reach a limit and we'll talk about that as a Malthusian limit in this particular
period.
Later we'll discuss that.
And then around here,
uh,
the industrial revolution happens,
and all of a sudden the population increases.
Again,
this is a logarithmic scale,
so it's,
it's not linear.
Each of these jumps is by a factor of several thousand.
Um,
so that's very,
very a ski Matteis version of,
of human demographic history.
And we're talking about this period,
what limited hunter gatherers to this level,
whereas farmers could go up to this level.
And again,
uh,
the obvious answer,
and looking at this kind of rough data is that it was food,
whoever then,
uh,
archeologists,
paleontologists go and actually try to examine this.
And there it turns out to be the data does not fit that theory,
uh,
terribly well.
So,
uh,
what archeologists do,
they dig up skeletons and uh,
they have a good representative,
uh,
set of skeletons from the last 7,000 years in north and South America.
And one study looked at more than 12,000,
500 skeletons.
So we're,
we're talking about,
uh,
a good,
a scientific sample.
And what did they find out?
These were set into communities and communities lasted,
uh,
so much time.
So you can date the whole archeological site to a certain period and the,
the medical anthropologists got into it.
And so are looking at the bones and dentition and all this.
Not only did they find the violence we talked about last time,
but these people were also sick there.
You had diseases at different times and you could see bone problems and how well
the bones grew and from the teeth how much calcium they had.
And all this.
And what does it turnout that contrary to the idea of progress that you'd think
the later people were more healthy?
In fact,
it was the earlier,
uh,
people,
in,
in the earlier individuals that were healthier and as time goes on,
the skeletons get less and less healthy,
that they're getting less food and less good food and ha we're more subject to
diseases.
It was quite a shocker when this state has started
coming out and the researchers attributed this decline in health decline in
health in large part to the rise in agriculture.
Two main factors say the rise of agriculture in the rise of urban living.
And we'll talk about the urban story in a moment.
Now if you again go like we did last time from the archaeology to the
anthropology and look at current hunter gatherers,
uh,
it's a little bit of a distorted study because nowadays,
almost all hunter gatherers have been pushed out of the good lands that they
used to live in until very marginal lands.
You know this from US history in high school,
how the European farmers pushed the either very early farmers or,
or a hunter gatherers and the American Indians,
the native Americans into Arizona and to desert into the bad lands in the west,
the dry bad lands into the west of the u s so farming peoples push,
uh,
hunter gatherers into inhospitable land.
Uh,
there's a story in the Smithsonian magazine recently about,
uh,
Bush pygmies in Africa.
And I don't know if you know a little bit about the history of African
demography,
which we'll also cover,
but the bond twos have expanded from southwest,
the bulge of southwest Africa basically all around and have pushed other peoples
out.
And the pygmies are one of the groups that have been very severely discriminated
against and really pushed into inhospitable places.
Another example is the bushmen of Africa who are pushed into the Kalahari desert
in southern Africa.
But even in the desert,
these guys eat 85 different species of plants and it's almost inconceivable in
their culture for someone to die of starvation.
Because you know,
plants will bloom some years and not bloom.
Some years they'll get a fungus some year or virus plants.
Any one species is not generally very reliable.
When you have 85 different species to survive on,
you're not going to go without food.
There will always be some,
uh,
group of,
of plants,
uh,
that,
that are going to be available to too.
And so you're not going to starve further.
The anthropologist live with these people and they start,
you know,
writing down what they're doing at every point in time and per hour invested.
The bushman get more food than the early agriculturalists,
not modern agricultural is who can drive a tractor and then,
you know,
an hour to do a lot.
But we're,
we're comparing,
uh,
hunter gatherers to the first stages of,
of agriculture.
And,
uh,
the Kalahari,
the Bushmen in Kalahari spent 12 to 19 hours a week collecting food.
And the rest of the time they used for a lot more sleep than then even current
farmers and a lot more leisure than farming peoples.
So life is,
is more generous to them.
Um,
and you have to think now,
this is for people pushed into a desert,
a very inhospitable place.
And now if they,
if you can imagine them living in a,
in a lush forest region where,
where they,
they originated,
uh,
life must've been much,
much easier.
So the amount of time exerted to get your basics of food and everything must
have been much of a lot less
and not only a two,
they have to work less and,
uh,
they get more food per hour.
But the variety of foods is very good for you because you need different,
men are a different minerals.
You need different,
other micronutrients need different vitamins.
And as we are bombarded with,
uh,
in the popular press,
a variety of foods is very good for you.
You don't want to eat just one kind of food.
So they had a very diverse and healthy kind of diet.
Agriculture comes in and indeed,
it enormously increases the amount of food because per acre,
when land is limited,
when you have a population densities,
which that land becomes limiting rather than your time or your need,
when land becomes limiting,
then agriculture becomes important because per acre you can get a lot more food
than hunter gathering,
but you have to spend lots and lots of hours to get that land to give you that
amount of food.
So,
uh,
the question remains is why are there so few white were there and still are of
course.
Why are there so few hunter gatherers that again,
it's a Malthusian,
uh,
type question that if we know they lived quite well,
we know that later people going to agriculture lived a lot less well in terms
of,
you know,
basics of life.
How come the hunter gatherer population did not increase up to the same level of
misery as,
as early farmers,
which is basically one of the earliest examples of a mouth doozy and,
uh,
type question mouth those thought,
those same kind of thoughts.
But for much later,
uh,
population.
Uh,
well,
one just the truth,
we don't really know the answer to this and it's greatly argued about,
but I can tell you some things that are known are current hunter gatherers,
uh,
have a moderate number of children and many survive.
They do not have an enormous infant mortality,
certainly not compared to later populations,
which I'll show you the,
have a huge,
uh,
infant mortality.
Uh,
if they are nomadic,
and I'll tell you about an example of that later.
They have to move quite a lot and that means carrying children around.
And I think Bonnie has sort of indicated to you,
even dealing with a lot of children in one places is difficult,
but the difficulty of moving,
uh,
with very young children,
you're packing up everything and moving for a very long time,
over a long distance is difficult.
And nomadic peoples,
uh,
very often she'll very clear signs of some form of conscious population control.
They know they can't cope with more than x number of children.
Uh,
we'll get to that.
All societies have indeed controlled their population,
but by mechanism they were not totally not clear what they think the reason for
their doing things were.
But,
uh,
nomads apparently know what they're doing.
A hunter gatherers are moderately healthy.
Again,
their,
their burden of sickness is not,
uh,
is not severe.
Compare it again compared to later populations.
And however,
parasites are always a problem.
And let me show you again,
a modern case of parasites.
This is a girl,
modern girl,
current girl in Central America,
and you may notice the swollen belly.
You know what's inside there to swell it,
right?
Worms.
Exactly.
And when they purge her,
that was what was inside that girl.
Although those ones,
so,
uh,
humans have had this problem since time in memorial.
Uh,
hunter gatherers are not immune to this infectious diseases.
They have less because they're in small groups.
So infectious disease,
you know,
need large groups to keep spreading.
Uh,
and they're hostile to their neighbors.
Just,
just again,
like chimpanzees.
So they don't come in a lot of contact with neighbors.
So diseases don't spread from group to group in each individual group is not
large enough to allow for the maintenance of the disease.
MMM.
Each village,
if you,
you know,
anthropologists go and sit in one village for a long time and they ha they,
they have a population growth rate each fill,
it seems to be expanding quite noticeably.
And you think,
well,
in each village that we go study population is increasing.
Again,
it doesn't make sense.
Why haven't they,
you know,
and living that way a hundred thousand years,
why haven't they filled up their space?
Why is each village surrounded by lots of basically unused space.
And even in,
in,
in today,
a lot of the very tropical lands are not highly densely populated.
We may have the image that they are,
but,
but uh,
but they're not new Guinea is not densely populated if you call densely
populated.
The Netherlands is,
I think the most densely populated in the world of Bangladesh,
the livable regions of China,
the livable reasons of Japan.
These are densely populated.
The,
uh,
the,
the tropical region of the world.
Nothing,
uh,
nothing like that.
Uh,
New Guinea.
I said Borneo,
very sparsely populated,
uh,
the Amazon sub Saharan Africa,
vast open area.
So these are not situations of high population density yet any village that you
sit in is increasing its population.
And so what's going on?
Um,
so what are the parts?
So what,
what the archeologists find out is that when they study a site,
and I sort of mentioned this already,
what you see is this,
you,
uh,
go to,
you'd start taking a site new,
you actually dig in reverse,
but you've go to the bottom and you see there was nobody there before certain
years.
And then a small population and what you say,
you can count the amount of food remains,
all kinds of things.
The population grows more or less exponentially.
That means that there's same percentage every year or a half of a percent a year
or whatever it is.
And it grows up faster and faster because there are more people producing that
same percent of population growth.
So you get this phase and then all of a sudden you reach to help you upon your
village has gone and there's not,
there's nothing there.
So some sort of a crash happened or if it's not totally gone,
uh,
it's really knocked down tremendously.
And then either wait,
look at that site again,
like the biblical sites,
which they dig and dig and dig and sometime later starts up again.
Or the or a different site starts up again and you get the same phenomenon and
forget this line.
This is the idea of a cat that was the carrying capacity,
but nothing is even see nothing fits the carrying capacity.
It just,
you know,
maybe stay there for a little bit here.
So the idea of carrying capacity for humans doesn't work very well.
Um,
so what are the reasons?
So,
and then the explanation for the population staying more or less constant and
not filling up the space is not that each community doesn't exist,
but communities,
here's your space filled with community a,
B,
c,
d,
and it's,
each community increases.
Some other commuter just disappears,
goes out of existence.
So if you measure over the whole big space,
you have a floating game of different communities,
each growing but then disappearing completely.
And the population in the whole space stays more or less the same.
I don't want to push that as really comes super duper constant,
but you know,
more or less the same does not fill up.
So what are the reasons why a community would,
would grow very happily?
More or less,
you know,
very vaguely exponentially and then go out of existence.
So one is of course,
climatic disaster.
Uh,
there could be a freeze,
a,
there could be a drought,
uh,
these,
these real climatic things.
And if you look at like the Anasazi of Arizona that live near,
near the,
the Colorado River and near,
uh,
regions,
one of the thoughts,
they,
they're one of the communities that fit this,
they're healthy and go see their ruins,
then they just disappeared.
How many of you have been to the Anasazi site in Arizona?
Oh,
just one,
one student,
something you gotta do.
Um,
uh,
and there you're living in a semi true desert now in a semi desert back then.
So climatic things are a reasonable explanation,
but you go into the tropical regions,
you don't have droughts that lasts,
you don't have freezes.
And yet you see this same kind of phenomenon.
So,
well,
undoubtedly climatic things happened occasionally,
uh,
in the temperate zone,
certainly in the northern zones.
Certainly most hunter gatherer societies,
probably that's not the explanation.
The next thing that could have diseases of the crops that some fungus came by
and wiped out your crops.
Well,
we've just talked about that,
that since they're eating 85 different kinds of things in the desert,
there isn't any kind of a microorganism that,
that cuts across species like that.
So that explanation doesn't seem to work.
Disease of humans,
same thing,
not diseases of the plants,
but diseases of humans.
Um,
again,
the data just doesn't fit that,
that because of the isolation,
uh,
they don't have a huge problem with communicable diseases.
So that leaves the possibility of violent confrontation from one community to
another.
We've seen in the chimps how the northern group will completely wipe out the
southern group and so forth.
So what kind of evidence can want to do so that this might be what's going on if
one looks at any modern population and looks at the survival curve.
So this is,
uh,
the,
the number of deaths per thousand per year.
So into,
this is India for instance,
and it's fairly recent.
1960s beef antibiotics are just coming in at this stage.
So very high infant mortality rate,
80 per thousand.
It's one out of every 12 kids now.
It's like almost immediately.
And then that high rate continues until about,
comes down to something about six or seven years old.
So a lot of your population is just wiped out immediately.
Uh,
and then you have a pretty low level of death and fairly flat until it gets to
be what's considered old age and different populations.
And then the death rate rises against you if this very standard u shaped curve.
And here after you have sort of modern medicine is a Sweden in the same year as
the infant,
primarily.
The main thing that the infant mortality drops like crazy and the old age stuff,
everything drops.
But the main drop is in infant mortality.
The idea is what I just want you to get out of this,
we'll see this graph again and again a couple of times,
uh,
is that during the adult years,
the death rate is very low compared to either here or here.
Now,
if you look at what we can gather from archeological data,
from hunter gatherer communities,
you have a high death rate among kids,
not,
not as high as when you get all these communicable diseases and modern
societies.
And then you have a flat and then all of a sudden there's this big bump that
there's what they call an excess mortality in exactly the young adult years.
And then it comes back down again and you get a more or less normal old age
situation.
Well,
what is it that kills people in their middle years violence?
So this kind of data and get,
again,
we don't totally,
we don't really know the answer,
but this kind of data leads you to suspect than indeed one of the major reasons,
not the only reason,
but a major reason that the hunter gatherer communities and the early
archeological communities disappears so suddenly is that they are wiped out by
some sort of violence.
And so we're right back in hunter gatherer times as far as we can tell,
uh,
to,
what you've seen before of these mass I've showed you last time.
These mass graves that are characteristic of this period.
Okay.
Nevertheless,
over the very long scale of time,
our period of being cavemen and hunter gatherers lasted hundreds of thousands of
years.
Uh,
but gradually population did slowly increase and as population increases,
the land available to people gets less,
would talk.
I think next time about Africa,
which has a culture and with land is not a scarce commodity.
Now it's going,
it's getting to be scarce,
but a tradition and their traditions,
land is not the scarce commodity,
but as population grows,
the land per person gets less and then you have to make a more intense
utilization of the land.
And farming gets invented and a big discussion,
whether actually it was the population pressure that caused farming to be
invented or whether that was just some brilliant stroke by somebody that
invented that,
you know,
people slowly figured it out.
So,
uh,
they actually can trace the origin of agriculture to the current date is 11,700
years ago in the Middle East and Anatolia,
what's now a Turkey now
eastern Turkey.
And it expands on the average from the original sites.
You can watch it expand and it expands at one kilometer a year,
that's the average.
And then it eventually takes over the whole world.
And so the number of people and when you invent agriculture,
the number of people that can be supported on one plot of land grows up
enormously.
Uh,
we've seen that.
And so these people become more numerous.
And so in military confrontation's and warlike connotations,
they're going to be dominant almost no matter what the technology is,
no matter what the bravery is,
if you have an awful lot more people,
you're going to wipe out or push out,
uh,
groups that don't have that kind of population density.
Uh,
so agriculture spreads when the early days of agriculture,
you don't know an awful lot,
uh,
yet,
and you probably have one crop that you really know how to grow.
And,
uh,
for instance,
in the Americas the big crop was corn that most of Latin America,
even to this day,
lives on corn.
And the mirror of the North American Indians lived a lot on corn,
of course in Southeast Asia are great big pop things.
And it was rice.
And you basically live off most of your calories,
most of your food from one single crop.
So that's not very healthy because each crop is missing something.
So corn,
you may know Mrs Lysine,
one of the essential amino acids and a over a very long time,
the,
uh,
the Americans learn to rather complicated procedure for,
for boiling it in lime to,
to extract a,
this amino acid from the plant.
But until that was discovered,
they must've been extremely unhealthy.
Rice,
you know,
a is missing all kinds of vitamins and people have very severe vitamin
deficiencies if their diet is too much,
uh,
rice.
So you're not getting a health in early farming,
you're not getting a particularly healthy diet.
You're not getting the minerals,
the vitamins and micronutrients that that you need.
Furthermore,
your food security goes down.
Again,
as I've mentioned,
that a virus or fungus or something attacks your crops and you know,
if that's 80% of your calories and that is wiped out in a year,
you're gone.
Or if or if a locus Kumbaya and eat them up or some insect infestation comes
through.
Um,
also with increase in,
uh,
in calorie availability,
you can,
more people can stay alive.
Uh,
and so we get dense populations.
The social structure changes.
Now,
previously,
each person could only get enough food basically for himself or maybe a very
small family.
As you develop the technology of agriculture and individual can produce a
surplus,
not everything he feeds well,
who's going to get that surplus?
Then they get in an egalitarian society,
he keeps the surplus himself,
his family so forth.
But there's other guys that are either stronger or Nastier than you and they
come in and steal your surplus from you and they have to leave you just with a
small part of your production to just keep you alive because they want you to
work for them.
And so,
uh,
you get societies now where there are classes,
there are people who in one way or another,
take the excess food from the farmer and use it for other purposes,
usually their own purposes.
They can largely hire military to keep them in power and to protect them from
other places.
That's a large use of the food surplus,
which agriculture puts up.
Also,
manufacturers come in,
they,
they hire artisans to make beautiful gold objects,
uh,
for them or to make a beds or chairs or you know,
all the,
all the manufacturing starts on the agricultural surplus that agriculture brings
in because an individual human now can produce more calories than he needs to
keep going at a subsistence level.
So what you see as agriculture progress is a hunter gatherer societies.
They're generally quite a gala.
Tarian.
They'll more or less have a head man,
but he won't,
or a wise man or an old man,
but they won't have authority.
He can't order other people around.
The community has to agree on some project.
If they take undertake projects at all,
as more,
more food wealth becomes available,
society start,
uh,
stratifying.
You get social classes,
you get casts.
And uh,
this inequality changes everything about the way humans live.
Um,
the congestion in the cities.
Cities start growing up and then you start getting the spread of these
infectious diseases where one person spreads it to the next enlarge
agglomerations of humans.
And that just gets worse and worse up through,
uh,
you know,
the 14 hundreds in Europe when you get the black death and wipes out a huge than
than that is this.
As,
as civilization progresses,
the death rate from infectious diseases just keeps going on up.
Um,
adding all this together and the data we have is that hunter gatherers,
their lifespan is ballpark 50 years in early agricultural societies.
That goes down to 35 years.
So we're really,
and I'll show you data that in a lot of places it's probably even lower than
that.
So we have the situation where human w x not,
not counting violence that humans lived when they weren't being attacked by
their neighbors.
Humans were living very well.
The hunter gatherer society sort of Garden of Eden.
And then agriculture comes in and the vast,
massive humans become peasants be the land becomes owned,
not by them,
but by someone else.
And they have to give most of what they produced to someone else.
So life becomes miserable.
And there's a lot of thought that the various garden of Eden myths,
I mean,
every,
almost every culture has some sort of glorification of a very distant path past
where people did not have to work so hard in our culture.
We call it the garden of Eden.
Everything was perfect,
then something happened.
And after the fall of one sort or another,
uh,
now it's the sweat of our brow.
And it's a very nice description of what I've been telling you of,
of the hunter gatherers living in a lush environment before they're pushed into
the desert living quite well.
Uh,
however,
uh,
later on,
then they have to be farmers.
The sweat of the brow and violence like Cain and Abel is what is the,
the fly in the ointment of that beautiful,
uh,
Eden Story.
Okay.
So now we come to the agricultural period in our historical romp through history
and there's certain really fundamental,
uh,
issues,
that you have to understand to understand what was happening with population in
these times.
So there's constraints on po,
on human population.
And the first,
it was this enormous infant mortality,
which I showed you.
And again,
we're looking at 1960 here,
uh,
in a very civilized place.
You know,
poor India in 1960,
but still,
even even into the 1960s,
uh,
where we're very modern.
The infant mortality rate is enormous.
You go even currently to a less well developed place.
Uh,
he just cut out this quote from a Haiti in 1979 before this recent rash of,
of problems.
Uh,
Cornell train Haitian comes from Haiti to Cornell,
gets a medical degree,
uh,
returns to Haiti and he gets a job at a pediatric hospital.
40% of the infants of the babies.
So they have the,
he is working in a,
among other things of a maternity clinic,
40% of the babies were dying of endemic diarrhea.
A man would come to pick up the bodies three times a day with a big bag.
The noise of the skulls and the bag was unbearable.
And this is 1979,
uh,
in how far is Haiti from Miami?
150 miles or something like that.
So the data,
we have various data sets for what life expectancy was like.
And this is various populations.
Uh,
and what this is,
is a survivorship curve.
So you take for a thousand people born in any given space of time in an earlier
period.
So this is Swiss alpine goal.
This is Roman times.
Uh,
that's the part of goal is this side of the Alps.
According to them sis Alpine goal
out of the thousand children born.
And actually this shows females,
but it's more or less the same for males.
Uh,
almost immediately half of them die.
And that's very characteristic of human societies until modern sanitation comes
in,
which is in,
in Europe,
17 hundreds and in Asia,
maybe 19 hundreds,
um,
that you have this tremendous death rate of children.
And then it continues,
uh,
at a,
at a fairly high but decreasing death rate.
And then finally,
there's very few people left.
So this is not the curve which showed you the percentage of deaths in each age
thing,
but how many people are still surviving?
So at any point in care by age,
uh,
15 here,
this dotted line,
only about 40% of people are still alive,
60% have died before age 15.
And this again is women.
So a lot of this death in this middle period,
by the time this,
the reproductive years,
these dotted line is 15 to 45 or so.
[inaudible]
I think 50 in this case,
which is the years in which women can reproduce.
And most of the death and females in this period is childbirth itself.
In a developing population,
in a premedical population,
childbirth itself is one of the most dangerous things in these years.
And the death rates are very high,
uh,
from,
from childbirth itself.
So a lot of that is,
is a female is childbirth.
If you looked at a male population,
it might even be more extreme,
uh,
due to probably do the violence that we've talked about.
Now,
as time goes on,
we're going to come back to this graph,
but as time goes on,
this is Italy in 1921.
And things have gotten at all ages.
The death is less.
So there's more people surviving.
And then you come to Japan in 1984 and you're very,
very little infant mortality,
very little mortality through this period.
And then again,
old age takes over and people do die.
And this kind of bump here compared to say,
this is again,
possibly violence,
uh,
in that era.
But again,
we don't really know.
So for our purposes going back in time,
we're really interested in this lower graph,
which is characteristic of humans from way back till really almost Napoleonic
times,
and maybe throw in Napoleonic times,
but the deaths or the violence in Napoleonic times was enormous.
If you look at women,
consider this just to graph for women of a thousand women born 400 are still
alive at the beginning of their reproductive period,
and about 200 are still live at the end of their reproductive period.
So if you average that out,
something like it would be the same as if something like 300 women lived
throughout the reproductive period.
Well if that society is going to keep going,
what is needed to happen?
That these more or less 300 women have to reproduce a thousand women,
right?
And if they reproduce thousand women,
they also have to reproduce a thousand boys,
right?
So 300 women have to give rise to 2000 children,
And if they don't do that,
then there's fewer,
fewer people in each generation rapidly.
You don't see this population anymore.
So how many children is that that each woman has to have 300 women making 2000
children?
Six and two thirds,
almost seven.
So that means that in,
when you have a mortality curve like this,
which again is most of human recorded history,
most of human history,
not counting hunter gatherers who did live longer,
apparently,
uh,
the absolute minimum that a society could cope with is women having basic,
an average of seven children.
But wait a minute,
I've made this a better case.
That's of the all that this graph shows is women that are alive in this period.
What fraction goes in fertile?
What fraction have infertile husbands,
what fraction never get married?
What fraction are too sick to have children?
What fraction of women are worn out after two or three children and can't bear
many.
That's also very large number,
which depends on the population.
So if you subtract those,
let's call them in fertile women for a variety of reasons in which they,
or their husbands or their health,
they're infertile,
then there's even fewer people alive.
And so this curve goes,
if you didn't graph just women alive,
but women that are alive and in child bearing condition,
the curve gets much lower.
So the number of children that women,
the women that were physically capable of it,
uh,
had to have in these premodern times was more than seven and probably eight or
nine or you know,
you have to do the calculation and uh,
people don't know how to,
how to evaluate the,
what fraction of Roman women were fertile or infertile.
So
you can't calculate that.
So we have a huge problem that,
um,
that somehow there must be cultured.
There must be mechanisms to ensure that no women are wasted than any woman that
can reproduce,
does reproduce.
And when they reproduce,
they go at it.
They just keep going and going.
And of course men have an equal part.
I,
well,
they don't do the amount of work,
but they have a part in it.
So,
um,
and as I said,
this level of mortality continues into quite modern times.
It's,
it's,
it's quite striking.
Europe got out of it a little bit earlier.
I say somewhere in the 17 hundreds,
but for instance,
in 1912 in Australia,
we have an Australian ta.
Is She here?
Jay went to the,
she's got a ticket to the inauguration.
1912 Australian census shows that 60% of all children born died.
Unmarried.
So that's this number we have them.
Well,
it's about the same number as this for this shows that only 40% are left.
And this says in Australia,
60% are dead.
So that's,
that's the same number.
Uh,
60% of children born,
died on married and among the married,
one,
ninth of marriages were sterile and just 11% of the men and 14% of the women
produced half of the children.
So,
uh,
that means those that could reproduce,
were married and et Cetera,
had to really have very,
very high birth rates.
As late as 1912,
China as late as 1930,
uh,
had a nearly aboriginal,
a birth and death rate,
the total fertility level was at these levels of six,
seven,
eight,
eight children per woman.
He hit the population was not increasing,
which means the death rate was just as high and they were in this kind of a
situation for reproduction.
We can talk a lot about China later,
of course,
at that death rate.
And this is data for China in order to have a 50% certainty.
So as,
as you know,
uh,
many cultures and Chinese included in traditional times for sure wanted at least
one child,
uh,
to survive.
And so they do a calculation at this death rate.
How many children's a minimum,
you have to have to give yourself a 50% chance of having one son survive five
children.
So if you're not thinking of reproducing the population,
but just reproducing your own family,
which is the way individual families thinking and they have to have a son and
you have this mortality rate at five children,
you have a 50% chance.
If you want to have a 80% chance or something,
you're back up to eight nine 10 children,
which explains the,
the,
the desire,
not necessarily,
they don't like keep this birthright,
the desire for these very,
very high birth rates.
So the result is that in most a premodern societies,
women spend their whole post pubertal lives,
either pregnant or lactating.
Here's basically never a time when they're free of the bio.
The biological aspects of child bearing,
not not counting the,
the,
the children that are,
that are now not breastfeeding anymore.
The bunny was talking about.
So for instance in Bangladesh in the 1990s were coming up very close,
75% of the women in the age group of 20 to 30 on were either pregnant or
lactating.
Does that means four out of every five women were at that moment.
Any moment that you look there were either pregnant or breastfeeding and there's
a small period in which they rest and then it starts over again.
So we're not talking in,
in,
in the need for these very high birth rates.
We're not just talking about primitive tribes,
but by any means.
We're talking about the period in which all the world's great civilizations
developed and civil.
Say,
one of the things that civilizations had to do was ensure a birth rate like
this.
And in the,
in the period in which cultures we're learning to write and producing their
classic literatures and developing the great world religions.
All of these,
if you read through them,
are our calculus or calculators in some sense to keep fertility high.
All of the things glorify high fertility,
uh,
the,
the religious doctrines,
uh,
push it.
Um,
there's community sanctions.
The is just develop
that in order to increase fertility in any culture that doesn't do that and it
doesn't increase it successfully.
They're just not here anymore.
And of course,
most cultures that you read about are not here anymore.
And they were not,
not successful in our,
uh,
western culture.
The,
the most,
uh,
famous of,
of these things is the first commandment in the Bible to them be fruitful and
multiply well that,
that fits us.
If you didn't do that,
they're,
the Hebrews would be gone and we wouldn't have any of what we,
we,
we currently have in terms of religion and he kind of the monotheistic
religions.
Um,
so there's all kinds and you look at the,
the cultural or religious tradition of any cultural,
you'll find all kinds of laws about regulating sexuality.
Uh,
no.
Yale students don't know much about the Bible.
How many of you know,
you know,
masturbation is supposed to be bad thing.
And do you know what in the Bible it's supposed to prohibit that?
Yes.
So it's the story of own and spilling his seed.
And do you know why he was spilling his seed or what the situation is?
There's different versions.
One is that he was having sex with his brother's wife.
Correct.
Why was he having sex?
So this,
she said she was sex with his brother's wife and didn't want to impregnate her.
That's correct.
Passed away.
Right,
exactly.
Because I have to repeat that this for the camera.
So the situation,
it's a very short passage,
very interesting passage.
Uh,
and uh,
it's giving out very small section,
giving out moral laws and it says,
uh,
someone had sons and one of them was [inaudible] and Irwin's bang or died.
It doesn't say much about her except that he died owning with the next brother
repeated in the old test in many times is that if a man's brother,
man's brother dies,
he has the moral obligation to inseminate the sister,
the,
I'm sorry,
the sister in law in order to secure on air for the dead brother.
That if he,
if he father's a child with his sister in law,
then that is not considered his child.
Uh,
it is considered the dead brother's child.
And that's one of these important things of carrying on the family lines,
which is one of the ways that of course insurers are high population rate.
That.
So,
uh,
this is the way of keeping women,
whether they're married or not,
whether their,
their husband's dead or not,
you got to keep them reproducing or the culture disappears.
So why doesn't want to do this?
Why doesn't own in want to do this?
Well he may or may not,
it's not his kid.
So you know,
born.
So there's none of this sort of a power and authority and Macho stature to come
with having a lot of kids.
Cause it's the brother's kid and the culture.
It's was the brother's kid.
But on top of that,
he would have to support this kid that economically he would have to support not
only the wife but the kid.
And he didn't want to have to support kids that weren't his.
So he engaged in the sex act cause that was the fun part of it.
But at the last minute he pulls out and spills the seed upon the ground.
And then the Bible passages,
very curt,
it doesn't say more to z and then God killed them.
No,
there's not a lot of explanation for this,
but it's repeated.
This particular law that called the levy rate laws,
as students said,
is repeated in several places in the Bible.
And it's very,
very clear that people didn't do this.
People did not in salmon,
did not want to inseminate.
They're there,
they're brothers wives because of these reasons.
And so whenever you see a law sort of demanding something over and over again,
you know,
people weren't doing it.
And that's why the law is,
is demanding it.
So that's just one example of,
uh,
how,
religion gets involved in enforcing fertility.
And in this picture example is one of the mechanism for every woman pregnant as
much of the time as possible,
independent of her state of marriage.
So the,
uh,
anybody know why,
the Muslims took to polygamy?
Why Mohammed allowed for wives?
No Muslims in the class.
Great.
What
do you like very limited.
No,
but the standard version is they were going through a lot of wars.
The most songs were conquering the whole word.
They were constantly at war.
The men were getting killed.
There weren't enough men.
So what do you do with the other women that they,
I mean many reasons,
but one of they,
they need support.
And so that's it's a benefits thing,
but the society needed more men,
more children.
So let,
let them get married.
Uh,
multiply and you're just whatever religion you want to look at,
you'll find similar kinds of examples
when we get to uh,
uh,
family planning issues later,
later on,
how,
how people control their reproduction.
One of the major beliefs that the earlier we don't really know again,
but in the West was at the mechanism people use with Koa center up this cause
he's the only thing they knew about cause it's in the Bible,
it tells you what you do,
it tells you the result of it.
And so that own in passage is currently interpreted to,
uh,
say that masturbation and,
and contraception,
all kinds of things are bad when in fact the past has nothing to do with that.
That's not what that passage is about.
But that's what it's used for today's.
But it's been used absolutely for the opposite.
People use this,
oh,
that's how I can avoid having children.
And so it's,
it's culture twist itself about and has unexpected consequences.
Okay.
So,
so I've been stressing for you,
um,
that culture pushes up fertility and up to this,
uh,
high limit,
but what is the limit of human,
uh,
fertility?
So we have to evaluate that.
And um,
so there's a very famous calculation of this and it's set by the number of years
a woman is fertile,
which is generally 15 to 45 more or less,
can be a little bit younger occasion,
a little bit older,
but they usually consider,
uh,
30,
30 or so years of fertility,
uh,
and at that will,
if she gets me,
she's going to be pregnant for nine months.
Uh,
[inaudible] rarely starts again before at least three months if she's lactating.
and,
and therefore we're going through not,
not obviating again,
that's going to be more months.
Ah,
if a woman has sexual intercourse,
it takes an average of five cycles to get pregnant.
We'll talk,
when we talk about abortion,
we'll talk about why that is.
But if a woman's having normal sex trying to get pregnant,
the average is five months before she actually does get pregnant.
We'll we'll see where that comes from.
Uh,
if the child dies,
fetal mortality introduces a month there.
Anyway,
you're all,
yeah,
all of this up and you get,
uh,
18 months that,
that sort of pretty much the maximum that that human females can do is 18 months
or one and a half years.
So dividing what they usually do is choose 20 any particular woman will probably
be fertile for 25 years.
You divide that by 18 months and you get a theoretical possibility of 16.7
children right now.
Uh,
how many of you know somebody who's had more than that?
What's the maximum number of children you know about it?
Sure.
18 I'm bid 18 that's the only one in the class.
Much higher.
How many have I was looking at the six
Oh no,
no,
I'm not 60 no,
nothing.
That's really crazy.
Unless there's some crazy multiple birth.
Now with modern modern drugs,
sometimes there's multiple,
but no,
not 60.
So this is an unusual class,
but as time goes on,
families get smaller and people don't remember.
Uh,
the maximum I got out of this class was 24 children.
One,
I think it was a Chinese student,
I don't totally remember.
And that 24 was only two sets of twins.
So they're 22 separate successful pregnancies,
two of which produced twins,
24 children,
uh,
one woman,
and even forget this,
independent of this calculation,
which I've just sort of sketched for you,
uh,
at the,
even before the calculation was done in the prison,
did the calculation knew about it?
Oh,
this is not,
yeah.
Here is the,
the uh,
the,
Norway in,
uh,
an earlier set of women,
which is this set and a later set of women.
And this is the number of children that the women have and the percentage,
the per thousand of women that had that number.
So in the 1880,
[inaudible],
late 1880s,
the APP,
the most common number for Norway,
again,
we're talking Norway,
eight 89.
We're not talking about him,
anything.
Very Pr,
anything primitive is 10 children.
The,
the,
the mode for Norway,
there was 10 children and it goes out to 18,
which was the record that someone here knew.
And there were of course,
if you had a bigger sample,
you'd get an occasional something more
world record.
It's 69 children.
Oh,
what does it say?
It's good for him.
And what,
what,
where?
That's something special as it say anything about it.
Oh,
okay.
So it was,
it was,
and what was the total number of,
yeah,
so,
okay,
I was wrong.
Send me both of you.
Send me the reference,
send me the reference for that because next year I'll use it.
Um,
so and now,
just as long as I've got this slide up there,
look what changes.
So we go from 40 years later,
not a huge fraction of time.
We're going to talk about this later in the class.
It goes from the mode being 10 children to the mode being two children.
There's something drastic happens in between these two,
uh,
in,
in 40 years.
And this is common over Europe.
This is just one,
one dataset.
And we're going to talk about that a lot,
but since it's up here,
so in this period of time that we're talking about,
women had this very unhappy in the mode is very large number of children and
they far exceeded,
uh,
the,
what's calculated as as the,
as the maximum.
Um,
let's see.
Okay,
so the answer is at the biological limit is very high.
I'll say 24,
he's a 69.
We have to read that stuff.
So in a human population that can end continuing for any length of time,
the highest well-documented fertility instead of the Hutterites in the 1920s,
anybody hear of Hutterites?
It's a,
it's a Christian religious sect that are urgent and what's called an Anabaptist
sect that originated in Europe,
migrates here.
They're in the upper Midwest,
in,
uh,
North Dakota and going on over in into Canada.
And they're very successful in both economic ways and in population ways.
Uh,
they marry fairly early,
not extremely early,
but fairly early.
They have a good diet.
They're farmers and very productive farmers and have good medical care.
They engage in sex regularly.
Uh,
they're supposed to.
And,
uh,
their religion forbids contraception or abortion.
And not only do they have the,
they obey these rules and many,
many people have those rules in the books,
but this,
this is a very religious group and they,
they obey the rules there.
Uh,
what we call total fertility rate,
which at this moment you can consider the average number of children that are
women in that society would have was 12.4 children.
Nothing that's high.
You think that's high?
So someone blanche here as an average children,
but nothing like the,
like the 24 or [inaudible] 69 that we're talking about.
So this is the highest human population that we have documented can have that
and it's nowhere near,
uh,
any kind of calculation,
for,
for a limit.
And,
uh,
the most usual limit you see a lot of cultures are in at least some part of the
history where the,
the,
uh,
eight is his current cultures were or historical cultures where eight is kind of
a,
a maintained average.
So in the colonial,
the United States for instance,
for short time in the frontier was wide open.
They had a fertility rate of eight children per women.
And uh,
but as soon as the frontier would close in a region,
uh,
the fertility rate would drop.
So it was clearly land availability had something to do with it.
And there's good data for Massachusetts.
Concord,
Massachusetts is very good demographic data there.
People have these high birth rates until the frontier closer.
What did the front tier mean in 16 hundreds in Massachusetts it meant like
Springfield,
you know,
these are people living in Plymouth and Concord and Lexington right near the
coast.
And the frontier was Springfield.
And as soon as,
so if they had a lot of children,
the children would have to move out to Springfield or somewhere,
which is what,
a hundred miles or something like that.
And that was beyond the frontier.
And as soon as the children had to move more than a day's draw,
a horse ride away,
the fertility rate drops.
So there's something about having the support of your children,
really having a group that increases the fertility.
And as soon as the children will have to disperse and not any more be of some
sort of support to you or some part of your group fertility comes back down.
So no society really has there has ever come close to uh,
the biological limit.
So before we talked about how culture pushes up the birth rate,
but now we say that something is pushing down the birth rate that were coming to
a,
an intermediate level.
And what's going on is again,
fairly straightforward and simple that I think it was,
come on
this slide that I want here is a,
again,
fairly recent data.
Chinese women interviewed in 1980 and 81 but referring to their pregnancies,
which had been some time in the past and it says it tried to gather data on what
was the birth interval of your children and how many of them survived.
So if the birth interval was less than two years,
45% of the children died.
If it was between two and three years,
34% of the children die.
If it was more than three years,
only ninth,
only 19% of the children died.
So in every culture and every time and place where we have data like this,
it's very clear that if the birth interval is too small,
the children just don't survive.
So what's going on with pushing down?
Uh,
the fertility rate is that it,
especially in situations of poverty where resources are not great,
women are not especially healthy.
There's no any kind of medicine available that if the child does not get a lot
of resources,
which large cases milk from the mother is the primary thing.
Cause there's like China,
there's no dairy products at this time in this social class,
uh,
it's largely food directly from the mother.
The children just going to die.
So the reason that fertility is a little push up from below is pushed down is
not to reduce total a number of children,
but to maximize surviving fertility.
What people aim at is not to just keep popping out and having them die.
But people aim at and,
and cultures have learned to accommodate.
Two is to maximize surviving fertility,
not total fertility,
which is just being born,
but maximizing the number of children that are going to stay alive to become
adult reproducing members of the society.
Now people have many mechanisms for limiting the birth rate.
A one that is often quite conscious is breastfeeding.
It's very standard method across many cultures.
Uh,
you've all heard of this lactational,
amenorrhea and uh,
many,
many cultures don't leave.
I mean in our culture,
women can breastfeed a little bit or a long,
it's totally up to the individual.
Many cultures are very strict
rules about this.
You must breastfeed for at least,
and there's a certain period of time and among the Kong of,
of a southwest Africa,
which these people that speak this click language,
you know,
and they've got all these,
you've heard of them.
Uh,
mothers keep the infant with them at all times.
They nurse all day and integral separated by only 15 minutes and that money,
how would you like to have that all day long?
Nurse Every 15 minutes,
the child,
they sleep next to the mother and have access to a breast all night long and
they can,
the nursing continues until the child is more than three years old.
And so by that mechanism,
primarily by the lactational Amenorrhea,
uh,
the,
the birth interval lung Kong's four years,
which fits is beyond this survival issue.
And this is the kind of,
I talked about nomads be bled,
ones that have fairly conscious,
they probably are aware that this is limiting their births and it's a thing that
they want to do.
Uh,
so when the women go foraging,
they carry their chin again,
the cone,
they carry their children with them until they're four years old.
And while carrying the infant,
she walks up to 12 miles roundtrip to Ford,
take six miles to go out and find some food and,
and come back 12 miles round trip.
And then in addition to that,
she carries loads of 15 to 35 pounds.
So here's a woman who being a hunter gathers probably fairly healthy.
She's carrying an infant on her back,
walking around 12 miles and coming back with a load of 35 pounds of,
of food.
It's quite a quite a feat.
And uh,
it's clear that they can't,
you know,
they're not going to have a second one on the back,
one on the hip.
This,
this is not a way of improving survival.
So one,
so that's a lactation is one mechanism.
There's many taboos on sexual relations,
especially after birth.
So in many cultures is,
uh,
as I said,
a prescribed period of nursing.
There's also a postpartum taboo against having sexual relations.
And again,
another obvious mechanism for births,
spacing.
And if you,
and again this gets to the degree of consciousness of these,
of these methods,
if you ask a member of a society that has a taboo,
they report for instance,
that sex at that time is very dangerous.
Uh,
a life and death matter.
it is dangerous to mix the man's blood with the woman's in the man's blood is
transmitted through semen.
It's a bodily fluid and they don't totally,
you know,
the biology is not very strong.
They're course.
Yeah,
it was terrible.
And so they will,
we'll talk a lot about,
not a lot,
some about what primar pre,
pre,
pre education.
People believe about reproduction,
everything and it and uh,
and if man's blood gets into the woman through his semen,
then it also gets into her,
her milk and then the man's blood goes back into the baby through the mother's
milk.
And this is a poison for the baby.
So that's,
that's their version of why they should,
why they have this taboo.
And we see this in the evolution of cultures.
I mean,
just as we evolve biologically,
we of course evolve culturally that cultures may,
we'll pick up a behavioral pattern for who knows what reason and they may have
no clue what it's real coat as we see it.
It's real purposes in this case to to space births apart.
They have some kind of cultural story about it.
And it doesn't matter whether that cultural story has any degree of reality,
if they've picked up a cultural norm that works to society is still here.
And that gets passed on.
If that cultural practice does not work,
not only reproduction,
all sorts of ways that society is gone.
Um,
so,
uh,
this postpartum abstinence is a major issue,
especially in Africa.
Now.
Uh,
the abstinence is up to three years,
which is,
that's the con that's sort of the mode of,
of this.
And Africa in addition to limit,
uh,
births.
There's another thing which again is a population limitation issue cause we've
talked about individual family limitation is you're trying to keep the kid
alive.
If the villages,
uh,
resource limited,
they may have mechanisms for keeping the whole population of the whole village
down.
And so in Africa especially and have a thing called terminal abstinence,
that means at a certain point in life the culture demands that you stop having
sexual relations.
And very often this is when your daughter has her first child after that your
grandmother and you're not supposed to reproduce anymore.
And it's interesting what,
what the reason for it to prevent con,
they perceive it as preventing conflicts between their duties as mother and
their duties as grandmother.
So grandmother is supposed to help raise the grandchildren.
And there's a lot of biological theory about why do humans somewhat unique among
animals?
Why don't we just die?
We females,
especially after their fertile period,
there's no reason for you to evolutionarily stay alive.
You know,
and most animals,
they don't have a postmenopausal period.
And the aunt and the theoretical reason is the grandmother effect that as a
grandmother you support the,
the children of your child and that increases their survival.
And so it's evolutionarily good.
And here in these tribes in Africa are basically saying the same thing,
that if you're a grandmother,
you're gonna have a conferencing,
taking care of your own children,
taking care of your daughter's children.
And that conflict is bad.
So you have to not engage in sexuality.
Up to the middle of the 19 hundreds,
uh,
in Ireland,
Rural Ireland,
people lived in how,
in households with,
uh,
many members of both sexes and several generations,
big multi multifamily houses,
and the Irish believed that there should be only one sexually active procreative
couple in a household.
So they also practice grandmother abstinence.
So these cultural items are,
you know,
they may seem a little outlandish to us in our modern day,
but they were effective.
They,
they,
they kept that society going.
Um,
and
another issue is Exxon gummy that just like chimpanzees.
It's again,
in most animals it's the males that disperse.
But in chimps and humans,
it's the females that disperse,
uh,
the females leave the community at birth,
I imagine go live with the man's family.
And so she's under the control.
Then in many cultures,
basically a slave to the son's family and the reproductive rules are then set by
the son's family.
And she has no choice in this.
And,
uh,
we'll talk about that extra.
So this out marrying,
uh,
so remember with chimpanzees were hostile to the neighbors around us.
Human societies are that same way.
So then I have a lab in Klein,
the professor,
and the next lab to me is from China,
a village near Shanghai.
And he describes this to me in China that he says,
my village,
which all the same name as him,
it's all a male bonded,
you know,
Poncho liner.
The males had been there forever.
They're all have the same last name.
They are hostile to all the villages around them.
So they won't marry the village around to get married and have to go to villages
away.
And they're still sort of enemies.
And in New Guinea where,
and you know,
all over the world,
that's the same problem.
You're fighting with your neighbors.
And yet you have to get wives from somewhere.
You have to,
you know,
exchange genetic material.
Otherwise you get inbreeding.
And so the Myakka they say in New Guinea that we marry our enemies and now this
is a great story.
Time is up.
I will continue this story next time.